كما افاد مراسل الجزيره بسقوط عشره شهداء
في قصف اسرائيلي استهدف منزلا غرب مخيم
دير البلح وسط قطاع غزه الليله
الماضيه قتله الاحتلال الحربيه استهدفت
قبل قليل في معسكر دير البلح غرب مدينه
دير
البلح منزل
لعائله الموده في
هذا
المكان
شال
المستخد لا تزال تحاول
هدم اه تحت الحزام ه شباب احناش نفضي من
فوق خ من فيقل فوق وم في
ه هو هو هو بتلاقيه
هو يعني انتشرت الشهيدين اطفال وطفل على
قيد الحياه والام الان شهيده صحيح ثلاث
اطفال واحد عايش و اثنين مستشهدين والام
طبعا الولد طبعا رضيع كان في حضنها الحمد
لله حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل يعني وجهت
صعوبه كبيره نحن انت شايف يعني شح
الامكانيات باقل الامكانيات واقل المعدات
قاعدين
بشتغل معنا من داير البلح وسط قطاع غزه
مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط هشام نرصد معك
جديد المشهد
في قطع غزه هذا
الصباح جديد المشهد ان الكثافه الناريه
باتت اكثر في وسط قطع غزه لا سما مخيم
المغازي ومنطقه الزوايده وايضا مخيمي
البريج والنصيرات هذه المخيمات او هذه
المنطقه الوسطى لقطاع غزه باتت تشهد
الكثافه الناريه الاعلى باتت تشهد عمليات
القصف الاكثر كثافه والاكثر حده ومنذ على
الاقل سته ساعات ونحن نرصد عمليات قصف
متواصله من من قبل المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
من قبل الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
وايضا من قبل الزوارق الحربيه الاسرائيليه
كذلك هناك طائرات مسيره باتت تطلق النار
على المواطنين في اكثر من منطقه لو بدانا
من مخيم المغازي وربما كان القصف الاعنف
في هذا المخيم قصف عنيف من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه التي نفذت غارات
ونفذت احزمه ناريه على مناطق مختلفه في
مخيم المغازي وجل هذه الغارات استهدفت
منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه ونقل عدد من الشهداء
والجرحى جراء استهداف عده منازل في هذا
المخيم كما ان الاحزمه الناريه نفذتها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه واستهدفت
طرقا وبن تحتيه في مخيم المغازي وبالتالي
كان هناك عدد من الاصابات لا سما وان هذه
المخيمات هي مخيمات مكتظه المنازل فيها
متلاصقه وبالتالي اي غاره اسرائيليه تدمر
منازل لا سما وان الكثير من هذه المنازل
في مخيم المغازي هي منازل بدائيه الغارات
ايضا طالت منطقه الزوايده منطقه المصدر
وكلها مناطق تقع الى منطقه المصدر تقع الى
شرق شارع صلاح الدين وكانت هناك قنابل
فسفوريه تطلق من قبل المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
وايضا من قبل الطائرات على هذه المناطق
ايضا منطقه الزوايد والشارع الاساسي
الفاصل ما بين مخيم النصيرات ومنطقه
الزوايده شهد اطلاق قنابل فسفوريه وقنابل
دخانيه على المواطنين وعندما نتحدث عن هذه
المناطق لا سما الزوايده ودير البلح فهي
مناطق ممتلئه بالن ين هناك عشرات من
النازحين من المصابين نقلوا الى مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى من جراء اطلاق هذه القنابل
الفسفوريه والدخان وايضا طائرات مسيره
طائرات كواد كابتر مسيره تطلق النار على
المواطنين في تلك المنطقه منطقه الزوايدي
شهدت عمليات اطلاق نار كثيفه من قبل هذه
الطائرات على المواطنين على النازحين
الذين نصبوا خياما في الاراضي الزراعيه في
الشوارع وفي مناطق مختلفه في منطقه
الزوايده لكن لاحقهم ال القصف الاسرائيلي
الى هذه المنطقه ايضا من شارع صلاح الدين
وربما المنطقه الفاصله ما بين مخيم
المغازي ومخيم النصيرات ومنطقه الزوايده
ايضا شهد عمليات اطلاق نار وشهد قصفا من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه ومن كثافه القصف
الاسرائيلي اعتقد الناس وشك ان هناك
عمليات توغل من شرق مخيم المغازي الى
مفترق المغازي على شارع صلاح الدين ولكن
سياره الاسعاف وطواقم الدفاع المدني توجهت
الى تلك المنطقه وتبين انه لا وجود لاليات
عسكريه اسرائيليه على شارع صلاح الدين حتى
الان الدبابات الاسرائيليه التي توغلت
وبدات العمليه البريه من شارع من منطقه
شرق مخيم البريج حتى الان هي ما زالت
متواجده شرق مخيم البريج ما زالت في
المناطق المفتوحه لم تتقدم الى داخل هذا
المخيم او الى قلب مخيم البريج الذي ايضا
ايضا هو الاخر شهد عمليات قصف اسرائيلي
عنيف وايضا المدفعيه الاسرائيليه لا تزال
تواصل عمليات اطلاق القذائف باتجاه هذا
المخيم منازل هذا المخيم الاخطر من كل ذلك
ان هناك عشرات من العائلات الفلسطينيه ما
زالت عالقه ما زالت محتجزه محاصره داخل
مخيم المغازي في منطقه الزوايده جراء
استمرار اطلاق النار واطلاق القذائف
الفسفوريه وقذائف المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
شكرا لك هشام زقوت مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا
من دير البلح في قطاع غزه